Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number you can
call in any time. That number is 2192. David P.
This is a really good voicemail. John Fetterman,
the Democratic Senate candidate in Pennsylvania,
running against television. Dr. Mehmet Oz had
a stroke not too long ago, and he has been
recovering from that stroke. Many right wingers
are now saying Fetterman is not cognitively there.
And so this caller says, hey, you know,
Trump brags about passing that Montreal
cognitive assessment. What if Fetterman
took it? Would that satisfy Republicans?
Speaker 2: Hi, David. I'm calling from Australia.
Just, um. Why doesn't Feldman just take that
Montreal cognitive assessment test? Yeah,
I'd love to see the Republicans. Let's look
very serious. She might love the show. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Obviously, the very Republicans who
say the Montreal cognitive assessment proves
Trump's a genius or whatever. They said if
Fetterman took and passed the Montreal Cognitive
Assessment, as he certainly would, they would not
be satisfied. It's a double standard. We all know
that the Montreal cognitive assessment is meant
to screen for relatively serious dementia. And
when Donald Trump bragged and then Sean HANNITY
bragged about Trump passing the test, we all knew
it didn't really mean anything. But they claim
it's proof that Trump is brilliant. If Fetterman
passed it, they would come up with a completely
different standard. So I think it would be great
if he did it. I think it would be amazing trolling
to say I got a perfect score on the Montreal
cognitive assessment I did as well as Trump did.
The Republicans claiming Fetterman is cognitively
disabled are not going to be satisfied. On today's
bonus show, we are going to talk about the civil
lawsuit filed by the Martha's Vineyard migrants
against Ron DeSantis. It is a fascinating turn
of events as a criminal investigation has also
started into DeSantis. We are also going to
talk about the scheme to steal $250 million
from the Pandemic Child Food Program. Disgusting
people, truly. Joe Biden has also endorsed a
bill to disclose super PAC donors. That's a
good idea. But what's actually in the bill?
And lastly, the Pacman Finance Channel has
launched. The first video clip is up. I would
love for you to subscribe at YouTube.com slash
Pacman finance and we'll tell you about the plan
for that channel and the behind the scenes very
soon on the bonus show. Get access to the bonus
show by signing up at join pacman dot com.
Speaker 4: Oh the bonus show where you
want to make money. Everybody
else that makes money to fund.
Speaker 2: Themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Thank you very much,
Alex, for that endorsement. You can sign up and
join Pacman Qcom. You can use the coupon code.
Big deal. 919. Big deal. 919. You get
a discount and we will see you that.